[Musique]
changement de décor la banlieue
parisienne et sa forêt de béton ici au
pré-saint-gervais un projet de zone
d'aménagement concerté va supprimer la
petite propriété pour laisser place à
grands immeubles celle et en dresser la
dizaine chez madame évident andré vous
allez être obligé de partir oui oui
alors oui ce que vous allez allez
engager en charriant peut-être sous les
prix n'ont cessé pas de réponse à la
ferme après que le sérieux c'est pas de
réponse elle
pourrait au foyer de la ville
s'il ya de la place alors qu'est ce que
vous allez faire de votre maison c'est à
vous elle est restée un mois oui mais
l'heure c'est une société qui nous l'a
acheté est ce que vous avez pu en tirer
un bon prix comme on en voit noir
généreux j'ai juste de quoi acheter un
bout de pain sec mis les bienvenus on a
quatre millions cinq qu'on a touché on
encore un million à suspens je dis bien
franchement malgré son ami que je
n'aurais jamais on ne retouchera
peut-être jamais alors vous regrettez
aujourd'hui me serais jamais une ambrée
non moi je regrette pas pour les bonnes
raisons parce qu'il va j'ai hâte de
[ __ ] le camp de l'acteur ici c'est mon
usine vallières ras-le-bol moi je peux
pas dire que c'est dégoûtant parce qu'on
peut rentrer dans ses propres on peut
manger par terre c'est propre mais on
leur donne certes mordez le moineau vous
voulez voir tient debout parce que c'est
la mode mais vous regrettez tout de même
aujourd'hui de quitter votre maison
madame de l'avoir rendu astrium et oui
oui malgré l'inconfort aujourd'hui parce
que j'ai pas mangé ces données devrait
racheter quelque chose ces travaux non
mais vous vous imaginez on va trouver un
propriétaire est ce que vous allez faire
madame andrée vos quatre millions et
demi vous allez pas aller bien loin
vous soyez l'assistance publique du tout
c'est tout
[Applaudissements]
derrière le périphérique qui encercle
paris c'est la banlieue anarchique en
surface et en hauteur banlieue bien sûr
qui se densifie chaque jour un peu plus
il au numéro 6 que nous voyons ici celui
du pré saint gervais et bien cet îlot va
disparaître à la place si 130 logements
des commerces des bureaux et quelques
équipements sociaux
pour rénover ce quartier la municipalité
a donc déclenché une opération opaque
elle a reçu son label d'utilité publique
mais bien entendu ceux qui habitent
encore lille au numéro 6 ne veulent pas
s'en aller sans une juste indemnité
la maison propose 160 mille francs 16
millions anciens anciens et c'est à dire
que je peux avoir un studio
c'est tout car alors que l'ag cinq ou
six pièces la municipalité va pas vous
donner un coup de main pour vous reloger
la municipalité vous prennent 40 % de la
valeur de ce qui vous payent pour la gms
cros et comme escroquerie on n'est
jamais si bien fait c'est autorisé c'est
légal c'est un truc que je peux pas dû
être
j'ai reçu un papier de la mairie comme
tout le monde
aucun lien qu'est-ce qui a marqué sur ce
papier mais non plus
25000 fond qu'est-ce que vous allez
devenir alors monsieur louis brun bayard
lièvre je peux vivre qu'avec mes garage
j'ai pas à l'autre est tout petit
centième du tout la maison retraite vous
y penser non
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
les propriétaires qui n'ont pas encore
quitté les lieux se sont regroupés en
association de sauvegarde pour protester
contre les estimations des domaines et
surtout pour protester contre les
méthodes
monsieur guy desjardins depuis près de
cinq ans ils ont dix ont fait pression
sur les gens
de façon à ce qu'ils ne
n'entretiennent plus leurs biens ils ont
muré
n'est bien aller quelques biens qu'ils
avaient achetés ils ont enlevé les
toitures de certaines maisons pour
donner cet aspect de délabré ils ont
également amené des bulldozer pour
démolir les maisons pour donner encore
un aspect de délabrement avant que le
juge des expropriations bien sûr les
lieux de façon à ce que le juge constate
que effectivement c'est un quartier et
disons qu'ils tombent au délabrement
la ville du pré-saint-gervais couvre 70
hectares et compte treize mille cinq
cents habitants soit plus de 200
habitants à l'hectare c'est l'une des
plus fortes densités de la périphérie
parisienne
malgré tout les commerçants vont les
emplois aussi alors pour rénover sa
ville le maire monsieur blanc lui et est
obligé de la densifier sur sa périphérie
aussi monsieur blanc lui a fait appel
dès 1962 à une société hlm pour rénover
lille au numéro 6 mai pour des raisons
financières la sphère ne s'est pas fait
précisons que 60% de la population et
logés en hlm j'ai donc dû
en raison des nécessités impérative de
restructuration et d'amélioration de
notre commerce local
le diriger vers un promoteur privé
qui nous apporte des ressources
importantes pour la réalisation des
équipements prévus dans cette zone somme
importante puisqu'elle s'élève à 6
millions sept cent cinquante mille
francs
avec cette enveloppe le maire va pouvoir
équiper sa ville crèche logements pour
personnes âgées centre culturel le
promoteur financera aussi une partie de
la voirie mais les adversaires de la zac
conteste cette façon d'interpréter
l'utilité publique à commencer par le
président d'association de sauvegarde
monsieur cohen
premièrement
il va être créée soit disant 600
logements dont 400 en accession à la
propriété
nous voyons tout de suite que la
densification va être 1,6 puisque c'est
prévu comme cela contraire d'ailleurs au
poste qui prévoyait 1
deuxièmement
qui va habiter ces logements
étant donné qu'il y a cent vingt mille
logements invendus dans la région
parisienne
ce n'est pas les habitants du secteur
car avec les indemnités que l'on donne
ils ne pourront absolument pas se payer
autre chose qu'un studio et encore
troisièmement
les bureaux création de douze mille
mètres carrés et nous savons que par un
journal qui ne peut être mis en doute sa
parole il y à un million de mètres
carrés en chômage en région parisienne
dans la région parisienne sombre alors
où est encore dans tout cela l'utilité
publique maintenant les espaces verts il
ya environ 2 promis 3000 mètres carrés
mais que cela représente-t-il
c'était à 600 logements à une moyenne de
4 personnes environ ça fait donc deux
mille cinq cents personnes 2500
personnes il visait pas à 1000 mètres
carrés vous voyez c'est même pas la
peine de faire la division payer tout de
suite ce qu'il reste
une bonne partie du commerce local réagi
vigoureusement contre ce projet de zac
que vont devenir en effet monsieur
madame berkowicz artisan coiffeur
monsieur deux chaînes qui est artisan
serrurier
monsieur berthelon qui est réparateur de
télévision est aussi monsieur robert
morale lunetier qui a créer 30 emplois
dans ce secteur
monsieur robert morale vous êtes un
artisan luthier dans ce quartier alors
comment ça va se passer bon vin nous
nous sommes expropriés c'est prévu
depuis trois ans j'ai actuellement une
trentaine d'employés c'est le très beau
problème puisqu'il faut que je reste
dans le quartier ou dans la périphérie
du quartier pour pouvoir les conserver
sont tous des gens que nous avons formés
et aucun ne peut nous son corps pour des
raisons familiales ou autres d'ailleurs
ainsi devront partir tous ceux qui
animent ce quartier faute d'argent pour
se réinstaller dans les nouveaux
immeubles
bien sûr le commerce local se meurt
depuis des années mais le nouveau
quartier arrivera-t-il à retrouver une
âme avec 6700 mètres carrés de nouvelles
surfaces commerciales
c'est à se demander si la municipalité
ne confonds pas rentabilité bien-être et
utilité publique et bien écoutons la
réponse de monsieur blanc lui et le
maire
la rentabilité ne vise au fond que ce
que la construction peut permettre
d'apporter à la commune en matière de
taxe d'équipement
c'est dire une rentabilité légal alors
est-ce qu'on a pas pu monsieur le maire
un peu mieux aménager cette rentabilité
prévoir un peu plus d espaces verts que
c'est environ 3000 mètres carrés qui
sont prévues
prévoir des équipements collectifs
sociaux dans le périmètre de la zac qui
ne sont pas dans le périmètre qui sont
pour les trois quarts à l'extérieur vu
l'exiguïté son territoire quitte à fait
certain qu'on ne peut pas
réaliser sur un seul secteur l'ensemble
des équipements socio culturel sportif
et scolaire sans ce promoteur nous
aurions dû attendre des prêts d'état
très difficiles à obtenir
car ils sont fonction d'une
programmation qui est l'ongle à
s'établir
mais le pré-saint-gervais sera-t-il plus
heureux pour autant avec douze mille
sept cents mètres carrés de nouveaux
bureaux avec ses vieux en foyer logement
et ces jeunes en foyer culturel
l'expropriation pour cause de rénovation
et pénible mais
nous devons pour l'avenir du pas saint
gervais
entreprendre ces opérations car c'est la
survie même de cette commune qui est en
question
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
la survie du pré-saint-gervais passe
donc par sa densification aux portes de
paris il semble d'ailleurs que la
commune n'est pas le choix mais at elle
vraiment pris la bonne voie la
restauration n'aurait-elle pas été
meilleure et moins dramatique que la
rénovation
l'exemple du pré-saint-gervais mérite
donc réflexion
[Musique]